well I would say first well one thing is
I think the Republican Party is
different from the conservative movement
and really especially in the post-war
period this is important to keep in mind
because there were also liberal
Republicans and so there's a lot of two
are not you know they're not the same
and also the concern movement i think
has had a lot of impact on Democrats as
well so it in some ways it's always a
little confusing what the relationship
is between the political parties and
these social movements well I think the
you know there are I guess there are
different schools of thought about this
but the concern perspective that
suggests that the ability of
conservatives to attract these very
dedicated grassroots activists in places
like orange county california that that
enabled the movement to just kind of
slowly grow almost under the radar
screen until it was a kind of
consolidated its power and that the
activists carrying out the work of the
movement we're doing really the same
kind of thing that civil rights
activists were doing or labor act the
union activists are doing their they're
slowly kind of meeting evil one on one
holding coffee clutches participating in
rallies that kind of activity and slowly
but surely they built a movement
I think though that it actually is
problematic to see conservatism as a
purely grassroots movement and that one
of the things that really makes the
conservative movement different is that
it's always been able or throughout the
post-war period it's always been able to
attract a lot of support from business
organizations and from very wealthy
individuals and donors and that they're
that these people have played I would
argue a disproportionate role in driving
the movement forward so in some ways
what you really need to kind of ride out
defeats but you need to ride out you
know the losses that are part of any
attempt to change society one thing you
really to need is you need money and
need an infrastructure and conservatives
have access to that in a way that I
think labor activists just don't and in
civil rights activists don't and so they
are able to you know survive to feed in
part because they are connected to
people who have a lot of social power
regardless so I think you know the glass
your document is important part of the
story but it's not the whole story you
need to look at the financing and the
institutions and the role of the role of
companies and these groups that don't
rise and fall with elections or with
particular legislative battles
right do people see conservatives
differently well I think it is it's I
think really since the election it's
interesting we've seen an enormous
amount of condescension and hostility
that from liberal groups towards
conservatives and it is a combination
it's both seeing them again is really
weird you know freakish outside the
mainstream and you know a lot of the
ideas that are being circulated in the
consumer they are kind of crazy and
paranoid I mean the idea that Obama
isn't really an American or the idea
that you know that this the image of the
death panels for health care I mean
there is something really paranoid about
these ideas you know at the same time I
also think that it is it it is confusing
and it obscures the way things really
are to treat these people as though they
are you know with this with this kind of
just looking down on them and their
ideas and also I I guess one thing about
it is it it it merchandises the extent
to which a lot of the ideas of the
consumer I really entered the mainstream
and I think one of the things that we
really need to look at today historian
anybody interested in politics is the
are the successes of the conservative
movement and the way that it really has
been able to shape both political
parties and the whole way that we think
about politics way we think about the
market the way we think about the role
of the state it seems to me that in some
ways what people should start to do is
stop studying only the conservatives and
start looking at you know the mainstream
and the consensus and how that has
shifted I think in large part as a
result to be the work of the
conservative movement but you know kind
of conceived broadly
you